♪ (MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
Hi, I'm Dylan.
And I'm Jacqueline,
Dylan's mom.
And we recommend Succession.
It's the only show I've seen.
-(DYLAN LAUGHS)
-And, uh...
I don't watch TV.
I'm not a TV-watcher.
-We watched, like,
three hours one time.
-We watched three hours.
I felt like I was back
in college.
-It was great.
-(DYLAN LAUGHS)
(BOTH CHUCKLE)
It's a peek into
the ultra-wealthy.
They just have a lot more
at stake,
seemingly, to them,
because of the money.
It'll be very serious
and all this stuff is going on,
and then they drop jokes
in it
that are super morbid as well.
Like ruining someone's life,
cheating,
making fun of being poor.
The season finale was--
We were snuggled up
on the couch,
and my husband's walking by,
going,
"What are y'all doing?"
We're like,
"It's the season finale!"
-Yeah, yeah, it was--
-Don't get embarrassed...
-I'm not. I'm--
-...'cause I said we were sn--
If you haven't ever seen
Succession,
I recommend you get somebody
that you really wanna
snuggle up with...
-(DYLAN SCOFFS) Oh, my...
-...and watch it,
because it's very captivating.
And I love to snuggle.
♪ (MUSIC PLAYING) ♪